i am thrilled to celebrate here with you  at the world premiere of black widow  the wait is finally over  let's go it's a huge fun action movie  for the fans can't wait for people to  see it  we're finally getting to see it's so  exciting thank you for waiting i'm  really grateful they're all here tonight  we are here to celebrate  widow we make these movies for you and  we finally get to see it you ready to  watch play play-doh  let's go  hello everyone thank you so much for  being the best fans in the world enjoy  the world premiere of marvel studios  black widow  we have to go back to where it all  started  it was amazing mind-blowing oh my god  it's gonna be a hell of a reunion  you